[Music]
hello everyone I'm Jason Cannell from
Sucker Punch productions we have a lot
to show you today about ghosting
Tsushima combat customization special
modes but first let's take a look at how
you explore the world of Tsushima
[Music]
[Music]
exploration has been at the heart of our
open world design since the very
beginning but you can't have exploration
if you don't have curiosity so we've
continually asked ourselves how can we
let the island guide you in the most
thematic and immersive ways possible
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
first a loom
[Music]
the guiding wind can take you to all
kinds of locations in the game like this
farmstead that's been taken over by the
Mongols can also take you to your next
big story moments or even help you find
rare collectibles but what about the
things that you don't know about you
haven't seen yet that you don't know
exist
keep your eyes peeled for other visual
cues smokestacks on the horizon is
interesting and odd shaped trees or
maybe even animals trying to get your
attention
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
stay away my god the spirits of vengeful
samurai haunt this forest
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Sushma is rich with exploration and
discovery whether you're just following
a string of torii gates that will lead
you to a high mountain shrine or maybe
it's just a fox trying to show you
something hidden in the woods
either way bring your sense of adventure
and let the wind guide you
[Music]
Lord Sakai
[Music]
hi this is Nate Fox from sucker punch
now we just showed you some exploration
but let's switch gears and check out
some combat
[Music]
we've ever seen a samurai movie you know
what to expect two warriors
sizing each other up waiting for the
other to make the first move
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
as you can see the Mongols are
everywhere on this island for Jin to
succeed he has to use real skillful
precision in fighting them no wasted
energy every strike must
yeah
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so that was Jen fighting as a
samurai but now let's see him take on
the same group of Mongols as the
dishonorable ghosts as the ghosts he'll
use every dirty trick he can think up to
even the odds even using fear as a
weapon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but Allah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you might have noticed that while
fighting as the samurai or sneaking
around as the ghost gin head on a
different set of armor that's because
the armor in this game actually gives
you different mechanical advantages it's
not just the way it looks
it helps accent your chosen playstyle as
you explore the world you'll discover
ohm amore charms they'll give you an
edge in battle but more importantly as
your legend grows you'll develop all new
techniques which transform gin from a
samurai into the ghost but the thing is
you get to decide how those techniques
evolve and grow over time it's always
worth keeping an eye out for dive
flowers find enough of them and you can
change the color of an armor so not only
do you get to choose how the ghost
gameplay involves but you can fine-tune
the look as well
[Music]
it wouldn't be a sucker punch game if it
didn't have photo mode and our new photo
mode we have features such as color
grading depth of field so you can focus
on the right objects we have a bunch of
new features that really underline the
motion and movement that's so great
about our game you can control the winds
direction the speed you can change out
the particles to different types of
leaves and fireflies you can even select
a track of music from our original score
that might be a little bit more fitting
so if we ended doing a photo maybe you
actually want to do a video there's
something here for you here's a few that
I've created
[Music]
[Music]
a Japanese voice track option with
subtitles is a perfect fit for our game
so I'm happy to say that before the
first scene even starts you'll be able
to turn this option on
Oh some like a cottage ni nani o musa Oh
something I don't know reason I hear
kono kata amo go with your horrible
stomach
[Music]
it's sucker-punch we are huge fans of
samurai cinema we wanted to create a way
for you to feel like you're playing your
favorite samurai movie so we created a
windy black and white film grained out
mode that you can turn on from the very
beginning of the game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today we've shared with you some of the
unique ways that you can explore the
island of Tsushima we've also shared
with you some of the ways you can fight
as a samurai or assassinate as the ghost
or customized jinn or play in special
ways but we have so much more to show
you in the future
ghosts of Tsushima comes out on July 17
thank you so much for watching today
we'll see you later
[Music]
[Music]
you